[Music]
welcome I'd like to welcome you all to
understanding human bias at scale with
cube flow and I'm really looking forward
to the presentation that we've got in
store here today my name is Paco Nathan
and it's a pleasure to get to introduce
a couple of friends here let me get the
right clicker going
so it's pleasure to introduce Michelle
Cass bond and John Bohannon I have met
Michelle years ago we have one of my
favorite startups in San Francisco from
a few years back ad bond and definitely
deep bench of working in natural
language processing and now through
other conferences I know we've done some
talks and whatnot hosting before but now
at Google working on cue flow also John
I've met through another one of my
favorite startups in San Francisco
primer AI and John's been leading a
protocol quick similar you may have seen
a wired article about this last fall
roughly octobrush or so and anyway we'll
dig into more details they can both talk
much more about that I've spent a long
time working in the field and NLP has
been a large part of my career language
has so much power there's of course the
famous truism about the the pen being
mightier than the sword language has so
much affect for good and bad and we're
going to dig into how to process that at
scale but also some of the implications
so with that let's go there is the Dory
app if you're not familiar with it
there's some instructions up here about
how to use the app to put in questions
so down toward the bottom there you see
the blue circle it says Dory Q&A so you
can use the app to submit questions
during the Q&A we have a lot of time to
that there's also though a microphone
right here it's up toward the back of
the second row there if you want to come
up and get on the mic I think for what
it's worth we can probably field
questions and be because
don't think that we're recording so we
can do that as well now without further
ado please welcome Michelle angel
[Music]
Thank You Paco for that warm
introduction so in terms of our agenda
today we'll start out by talking about
the problem of human bias what makes it
so difficult to tackle and how we can
use machine learning to help out I will
take you through some of the major
challenges that we faced and how we use
cube flow to address those challenges
and we'll close out by giving you a real
world example of bias busting in action
a quick note about the images on this
slide special thanks go out to Ben
Swanson and Arthur for creating an AI
generated 3d model it was built on cue
flow it's a fractal that uses the
inverse of Pi as one of its parameters
so file that away in your brain because
you'll find out the significance of that
later let's get started okay I'm gonna
do an experiment with you
so everyone do me a favor and close your
laptop's at least for five minutes thank
you alright ready if you've done this
experiment before if this looks familiar
keep it to yourself don't spoil the the
others it's a very powerful effect when
it works so I want everyone to have this
experience okay here we go
ready
a boy and his father are in a car crash
the father's killed instantly the boy is
rushed to the hospital and prep for
surgery with one of the best surgeons in
the country lucky him doctor arrives
sees the boy on the table and says I
can't operate on this patient he's my
son now when I first saw this myself a
couple years back I was absolutely
stumped like my mind just like raced to
explain the paradox
you know like I'm sure right now in your
minds like you're you're coming up with
explanations for this so who is the
surgeon Michelle there's a simple
explanation for this it's the mother
raise your hand if you've seen this for
the first time and you immediately knew
it the mother was the answer 1 2 3 3
okay that's that's a little bit lower
than average typically 85% people are
stumped by this which means I guess by
extension like more than three out of
this room typically get it but don't
feel bad
I was also totally stumped by it
Michelle was totally stumped by it you
are just a good learning like machine
you've been trained your entire life on
a stream of very very good data that
supports the prior that surgeons are men
so you know that's cognitive bias the
reason that felt hard was because you
have cognitive bias we all do and so the
goal and we're going to describe one of
these is to find technologies that can
help us identify these biases that we
have and help us reverse them so here's
a system that's built on human decisions
so Wikipedia is an example of a web
scale system where it's really just
amplifying the individual decisions of
individually humans so what happens is
all those cognitive biases in those
brains get inherited by the web-scale
system
you just can't avoid it it ends up
happening let me give you some examples
but before I do I just want to emphasize
the astounding thing about Wikipedia is
that it works at all so I'm gonna I'm
gonna be pointing out some some
well-known problems with Wikipedia but
that's by no means a deal breaker it's I
use it every day I'm sure like most of
you do as well it is the world's most
important first point of information
about most topics and yet there's
absolutely no one in charge of this
thing it's it's really just a big
volunteer effort
millions of people deliberating with
each other to reach consensus on facts
about the world worth knowing so let me
give you an example so if you've never
heard of Donna Strickland I hope that
you'll never forget her now so last year
she won the Nobel Prize in Physics for
her work on laser physics first woman to
win this prize in 55 years it's a big
deal on the day it was announced the
world was astounded to discover that she
had no wikipedia page she now has a very
long very detailed Wikipedia page like I
can't even capture the entire table of
contents on the screenshot you may be
surprised to learn that all that
information that you can now learn about
this person did not appear overnight it
is not the case that she won the Nobel
Prize and suddenly there was all this
information available that was really
significant and notable that you know
deserved a Wikipedia page he was always
there somehow we just missed it let me
also point out that on that very day
this fellow won the same prize with her
this is her co laureate he has a much
less detailed page but it has existed
since 2004 let me show you an example of
a typical webpage a Wikipedia page about
a scientist I found this guy at random
just using my data totally typical meat
and potatoes Wikipedia page about a
scientist you know is based at some
research institute has studies a certain
topic and has had some public impact
there
sigh table reputable news sources about
this person and his work and so you get
a Wikipedia page totally normal
nothing controversial here now in the
same query where I found him in my data
I found a colleague of his who works on
almost the same thing very very similar
topic Public Health there's actually
more to say about this colleague of his
I would love to show it to you except
it's it's pretty hard to fit it on this
screen her name is Amy Zota and the
reason it just won't fit on the screen
is because there's this huge warning
banner stuck on her page this is
basically the the process by which
Wikipedia pages get deleted so the
community basically first it starts in
the talk page where they say you know
this person just isn't that notable then
someone decides to slap a big banner and
eventually essentially this gets fixed
or the the page gets taken down so
there's no bad guy here there's no like
evil group of people out to delete
scientists from Wikipedia these are
these are good citizens just trying to
keep Wikipedia standards high but the
problem is it's a subjective decision
how do you decide whose page is not
worthy of the world knowing you you know
you just have to use your gut and that's
just an invitation for your cognitive
biases to have an effect so I also
wanted to show you an example of the
opposite effect how many of you have
ever heard of sting now take your hand
down if that sting was the singer anyone
still have their hand up oh very strong
very strong okay I want you to keep that
in mind but here's here's here's an
example of a scientist who has the
longest and most detailed Wikipedia page
of all so there is no female scientists
who even come close comes close to this
and it's not because it's the most
important
in the world or her work is that
important it's because her life
intersects with a topic that people just
like to pay a huge amount of attention
to namely the post 9/11 war on terror so
you know this is just to show you that /
attention can also be a result of
cognitive bias now here's here's your
favorite stain her page the one I just
showed you was 10,000 words long
this one's 20,000 words long and in fact
of all the occupations of people the the
occupations that have by far the most
attention about whom the most details
are kept on Wikipedia are updated the
most zealously so that every little
micro detail you know that you can
update them on gets updated are
definitely not scientists it's
professional wrestlers and it's not
because professional wrestling is far in
a way the most important thing about
people or the kind of people that you
most need to know about it's you know
that's Wikipedia for you it's a
crowd-sourced knowledge base so the
things we care more or less about get
you know de minister or magnified it's
an imperfect lens on our world and
that's okay but wouldn't it be great to
be able to like map out this bias like
before we can fight against our
cognitive biases you have to know even
what they are how do we get the tools to
do this so Michelle and I have talked
about this a lot if you're gonna build a
machine learning system it's really
helpful to imagine your the machine
that's really the the best first step
imagine you're the computer what is your
task so let's say that you're the
computer and your task is to identify
all of the people who should be like on
Wikipedia and those about whom were
paying more attention than the citations
deserve like where would you even begin
well first you'd have to look at all the
existing Wikipedia pages there are five
million of them in English yes
news articles are being published every
day so thousands of news articles on a
daily basis you'd have to read all of
those hundreds of thousands in English
alone come up with the important
information and one set that doesn't
exist in the other set
could've been possible for human and do
the dip so yeah really really sucky
tasks for a human you know we even we
have like an order of a million
volunteers trying to do this like it's
it's the largest such effort in the
world and totally not keeping up with it
they've measured the latency for example
when huge things happen in the world's
like and they're printed in newspapers
how long does it take before they arrive
on Wikipedia it's it's long like it
takes a long time unless it's about
professional wrestling in which case
it's instantaneous so this is the kind
of data that we need so this is an
actual screenshot of the data that comes
from the system called Quicksilver so
I'm at a start-up just up the street
called primer and what this thing is
doing is it's reading all the news in a
few different languages but everything
I'm going to talk about today is about
English and it also reads Wikipedia of
course and what it's doing is it's
extracting facts about the people and
then writing summaries about them and so
this is what we need so how many of
these people actually are described in
Wikipedia so now what you have is a
ranked list right you can sort how much
did we learn about these people in this
case scientists in this case female
scientists how much did we learn
automatically with an AI system from the
news versus how much is known about them
in Wikipedia tada
hardest problem effectively solved so
when we first started talking about this
when we got a lot of coverage in Wired
for example last year we were we being
primer were like really really proud of
this pretty much smug because we only
had like you know tens of thousands of
people being tracked with an order of
you know hundreds thousands
of news docs and we did it from static
Jason L files so really really not
scalable and so since then we've
basically been getting the system on to
kubernetes and trying to make it
actually work at scale and we
immediately started to run into problems
and Michelle came and gave us that
consultation yeah so when I first got my
hands on Quicksilver I set out to look
at the existing architecture figure out
how it was built it was originally a set
of separate pieces running in a
hand-rolled kubernetes cluster on AWS
and I had one key question for John as
you scaled the number of people you were
looking at what kind of performance were
you seeing bad yeah so it seemed fine
with just the first few thousand but as
you started to grow to what kapeniak
scale you ran into challenges this is a
very familiar problem you have this
handcrafted artisanal ml system that's
been meticulously sculpted for solving a
tangible problem you have a relational
back-end document store a caching layer
and a monolith that coordinates between
all of those pieces with that as a
starting point the first thing we do is
forklift it into GCP some of this was
easy for example moving the kubernetes
manifests onto gke was straightforward
thankfully you were already running
kubernetes and we moved some of those
application config files into config
maps and database credentials into
secrets we even moved the document store
from elastic into cloud storage elastic
was overkill for this application so we
used the simplest storage we could find
but other things were a bit harder when
you stand up your application what's the
first thing it does yeah so step one hit
postgrads and talk to the knowledgebase
and that's also step and it basically
has to iterate back and forth back and
forth back and forth with
sequel calls yeah so I noticed that
actually moving the data from Postgres
into cloud sequel was just delightfully
straightforward but connecting to it was
another story so if you haven't used
cloud sequel before I'm
you want to run an application inside of
kubernetes engine you need something
called a sidecar that gives you a proxy
a connection proxy and what it does is
it creates a network tunnel it
continuously refreshes your SSL
certificate it can be a bit tricky to
set up but once you get it running you
generally don't have to think about it
okay so now that we have it running in
GCP great now you have two problems yay
your application runs poorly on two
different clouds mission accomplished
yeah so it is still like directionally
correct though because you know although
we're talking about scientists and
Wikipedia as a motivating example we're
actually building products so you know
what our customers want is a system that
you can just feed in natural language
documents it will automatically stand up
a knowledge base and update it as it
learns things from those documents and
then describe itself in natural language
reports of some kind and always
comparing it to self
comparing itself to some source of truth
so that's that's the generalizable
system we're going for and so we want
this thing to be able to deploy on any
kind of cloud or or on Prem actually a
lot of customers need this to work on
Prem so if we can make it work in both
AWS and GCP it's definitely a step in
the right direction okay so the primer
team did this the hard way sometimes a
monolith is okay but in your case having
a design template would have helped you
build a scalable application from the
beginning okay but just note that queue
flow did not exist when this project
started yeah so it's not too late Cupid
can still help so let's look at how I
prepared a recording for today what
we'll be doing is spinning up clusters
and watching nodes scale up and down and
performing training which is about as
exciting as watching paint dry so we'll
skip over some of those boring parts and
we'll start by looking at our empty JCP
console so from a blank slate the
question is always where do you begin
primer was brand new to GCP so we
started with an empty project and what
we need is a way to create a fresh
from scratch well good news there's an
app for that called quick to deploy and
if you go to deploy cube slow cloud
you'll find this form we need a couple
pieces of information we have a project
name we need to give our deployment a
name let's call it QB let's give it our
credentials if you're not trying to
create those their instructions on the
left and that's it we're using the very
latest version of queue flow it was just
released last week so how many people
here have used queue flow before okay of
those who installed it themselves okay
all right
one person so you understand exactly how
hard this is
this application is getting rid of all
that hard work for you what it's doing
is spinning up a gke cluster it's
setting up the project creating service
accounts enabling api's and installing
all the cute flow components you can
watch those install it takes about five
minutes to get to this point where you
have everything running but it also it
gives you a public URL that takes about
another ten to fifteen minutes and once
that's up and running you can go into
your services tab find your ingress
service and just click on the link that
it gives you so what you have now this
is your central dashboard and this is
the entry point into all of the sort of
queue flow you eyes oh that's the
official installation that's what you
get if you just use the app but I always
do one extra little step for my clusters
I'm going to show you the sort of secret
backdoor feature it's one of my favorite
GCP features
it's called auto provisioning and it's a
gke beta feature so if you run this
command you can specify maximum limits
for CPU and memory and what it does is
when you run jobs on your cluster it
will scale the number of nodes up and
down based on the requirements that are
there so this takes about five minutes
or so but once we have it up and running
we don't have to think about the size of
our cluster so if we take a look at the
number
nodes that we start out with we've
essentially created a baseline we have a
node pool with two notes which is enough
to run all the base components and a few
extra jobs so we're starting off with
just these two notes okay so now that we
have our running installation what
exactly does that mean so we just saw
deployed out cue flowed up cloud if you
want to try it yourself you can go you
can go there we had a number of
different components I'm just going to
refer to them as ingress there's a lot
going on behind the scenes we'll talk a
little bit about it later but ingress
essentially gives us that public IP and
it's a single ingestion point into our
cluster it handles all of the off so
that nothing inside the cluster has to
think about it from there we saw the
central dashboard and that gives us
access to all the other dashboards we
have some for training some for running
our pipelines argo is the workflow edge
and the powers pipelines kata is a way
of performing hyper parameter tuning and
then we also have a notebook hub if
operators for running training jobs in a
distributed way argo helps us run our
pipelines can tip helps us with hyper
parameter tuning and once we have our
trained models we can serve them we have
a few components that help with that
tend to flow for tensor flow models and
Seldon for any Python model so at this
point we have a blank cupola slate now
how can I take an existing application
Quicksilver and run it in cube flow so
we can take your existing manifests and
apply them to our cluster but not from a
terminal what's the up what's the
language of your application is written
in Python and what about the rest of the
code base a primer pretty much Python
it's all Python so you have all this
Python expertise yeah let's use Python
yay this is what it looks like to run
our monolith on cue flow we create a
pipeline and each step is one of our
components well let's see it in action
and run our monolith as a pipeline
so I'll start by going to the pipeline's
dashboard and there's nothing there yet
so we can upload a file and create a
pipeline using Python we have a few
Python files here we'll look at the
monolith version and we start out by
importing our libraries and defining the
image that we want to use and we set up
two distinct steps and we compile those
into a pipeline we're using this
pipeline decorator and we set we set up
each step and the order we want them to
run in and then those last three lines
is what compiles it into an archive file
that we can then upload into our cluster
so we have our caching layer our
monolith step and if we just compile it
as is we'll get a file that we can bring
into our UI
well what's inside that file this is our
go workflow definition so it's it's
really detailed and long you can open up
that file it's all txt it's not binary
you can upload it directly as is and you
didn't have to write it you didn't have
to write it you could use the pipeline's
SDK so if we upload it we can see a
visual representation with two steps
caching and then our application and if
we want to run it we give it a name and
this will actually execute it on our
cluster so we can view it executing from
this UI including accessing all the logs
and we'll see what that looks like
so our Redis container it's pulling the
image it's creating it and then it stood
up our application this is my favorite
part I think this UI is really beautiful
so there we have it oh this is the bare
minimum so at this point Quicksilver can
handle daily workloads involving
scientists but for a generalizable
solution what kind of scale do you need
yeah so I mean if we're gonna power all
of Wikipedia editing for anyone in the
world who wants to track some entity
some Wikipedia page and have the news
automatically be processed and give them
updates on what's new then
definitely we're talking about web-scale
so there's no getting around it I hate
to break this to you but you need to
carve up your monolith no don't carve up
my mono lid
so this is where keep low components can
help this is what that looks like it's a
longer pipeline now it spit up into
smaller pieces you have a data ingestion
phase and once your data is there you
couldn't begin training and you can do
that in parallel separately once that
training is complete you can serve those
models and then stand up your web app so
that's the concept how do we actually
implement that let's kick it up a notch
how can I take an existing pipeline and
make it better okay audience question
what's the best tool for quickly
iterating on a Python file what are some
of your favorite tools
Jupiter notebooks excellent answer all
right okay so we'll start by going to
the notebooks app you read my mind
okay so what's better than hosting your
notebooks locally and competing with all
of your open browser tabs for resources
running it on someone else's resources
that's right that way you have room for
all the cat memes so what we're doing
here is cue flow provides this spawner
and we can spin up our very own Jupiter
hop instance this takes about two or
three minutes but this is all running
inside our cluster so we can access it
locally we connect right here and we
have our own instance so we'll go and
we'll find our microservices notebook
I'll upload our own file it was also
really great for reproducibility hmm I
can point you at the exact notebook
where I ran everything you can see how I
got it wrong it's a so fun fact about
notebooks the very first time I saw a
notebook I was in Paco's workshop this
was probably 2013 2014 I don't even know
if he knows this but I learned
everything I know about notebooks from
Paco that was a very beginning so you're
seeing you're seeing the next
here okay so this is our micro-services
version of Quicksilver the first thing
we do we're just using a stock tensor
flow image so we're going to install cue
flow pipelines on top of it and then we
import those libraries we define some
static variables so which images we want
to run which versions and then we
retrieve our database credentials from
secrets that way nothing is hard-coded
in github anywhere and then we define
each of our steps we ingest our data
first and then we train and this step is
kind of interesting it's doing some
unique things so we're making requests
for resources we're saying that we want
a couple of CPU cores and 32 gigs of ram
we're grabbing those database
credentials and then we're adding our
sidecar this is what this is what gives
us the connection to cloud sequel this
is a brand new feature thank you to
Eternity for committing that like two
weeks ago just in time for me to get
this prepared this is one of my favorite
things so this training step because
we're requesting resources just for this
one step that means that we don't need
it for the entire pipeline so being able
to specify it at a step level is what
helps us to scale out our cluster so we
compose our pipeline we define each of
those steps and the order we want them
to run in we generate our archive file
right here in the notebook and we can
actually kick it off from here as well
so we have a link that brings us
directly to our pipeline dashboard and
we can see our pipeline running so our
data ingestion ran just fine but our
training job I know that's small it says
this step is in pending state it's
unschedulable insufficient memory called
devops okay so what do we do let's do
some troubleshooting we'll drop down to
the container level let's see what's
going on with our training pod we have a
few more details in here and it looks
like okay so we couldn't schedule it but
triggered scale-up this is a good sign
this means that our auto provisioning is
kicking in and because we only had two
nodes originally and we wanted more RAM
than was available we can see this
happening if we go into the console with
you know it's spinning up DevOps is
already on it didn't even have to call
them so that all happens in the
background and as soon as that node
becomes available that'll take a few
minutes our job will complete and then
the rest of our pipeline can finish
winning because what's better having a
fat cluster up all the time or having a
fat cluster up just for a few hours okay
so the cool thing is that once that
pipeline is done the nodes disappear so
the node pool that was stood up gets
deleted and our application is up and
running okay so I talked about the
ingress component and I told you there
was kind of a lot going on behind it one
of the cool things about it is that
there's a reverse HTTP proxy so we can
just add a route to our external URL and
navigate to slash Quicksilver and we can
actually see our application up and
running hey there it is alright so what
has queue flow given us we've gotten
portability so that we can run on any
kubernetes cluster queue flows entirely
open source and it uses vanilla
kubernetes api so as long as you're
running open source kubernetes you can
run queue flow on top that means you can
run it on another cloud on pram or even
local there's no vendor lock-in we've
also gotten scalability so that means
that our costs can grow in line with our
user growth and we can be very
fine-grained about that and then we also
have composability so that our ml design
can handle web-scale those platforms
like queue flow make it easier and
easier to build ml applications it's our
responsibility to build ethical ml
systems our reviewing bias can have a
positive effect immediately now that we
have our system up and running what can
we expect to happen when we ask
Quicksilver what it knows about a fellow
speaker yeah so when I saw that login
screen by the way just like weeks ago
literally I was very excited
and to test it out we have been actually
taking the speaker's of this very event
just little bits of information about
them really just like name employer as
tuples key words if you have them but
really like it works just with name and
employer and feed them into the system
and it reads all the news for the past
several years at least and it tries to
find everything it can about them and
assemble together a profile and then it
hits Wikipedia and it's like well how
much do I know compared to what
Wikipedia knows and so yeah we we
actually we found someone who like
popped right to the top when when we ran
this so she had been pretty quiet in the
news until mid March March 14th in fact
is when things just like exploded and
anyone know the significance of March
14th pi day yes so there is an engineer
at Google named Emma who calculated
thirty-one point four trillion digits of
pi breaking the world record very easily
and like there was just a ton of news
coverage of this she did it on GCP it
was a cloud computing feat and sure
enough as journalists basically did
their job of describing this this
scientific feat and describing the
scientists behind it you started to
learn more and more about Emma lots of
little bits of string that the AI system
gathered together in order to have a
bunch of cool things to say about
someone now this was trained on
Wikipedia so it's essentially like it's
model of what counts as interesting is
you know everyone on Wikipedia so it's
just finding facts that kind of
basically are similar to that and
assembling them and can we run it yeah
so this is this is us actually getting
her profile from Quicksilver and tada
there she is at the top and this is this
is what the machine just like spat out
Hey there's Emma I know about her
and if you have the job of keeping
Wikipedia up to date with the latest
people in the world of science and what
they're up to and the discoveries
they're making this is the hardest step
how would you even have found Emma like
unless you're literally reading all the
news every day and just keeping track of
every single scientist ever mentioned
and then visiting Wikipedia to find out
what you missed that is like an
impossible task
so today actually as of early this
morning at night this is now public so
all of you can go to that URL at the top
Quicksilver dot primary eye and we are
just updating this every day
automatically and so you know once upon
a time what we were doing was I would I
would generate these spreadsheets of
data about scientists using Quicksilver
and then I would help people who run
edit-a-thons so that's basically you get
a bunch of people and you give them
pizza and beer and you edit Wikipedia as
quickly as you can to improve it it's an
editor thought and it's really really
hard work it's surprisingly hard work
and just those spreadsheets of data
output were incredibly useful that's
what everyone said so we ran them in New
York London Washington DC and the
feedback was just like very very
positively this kind of data is what we
need and then last week we actually had
a edit-a-thon just down the street using
these completely generated profiles
because one of the pieces of feedback I
got was you know those spreadsheets of
data about people is is handy but it's
pretty it's still pretty hard to read
like what we really need is to just have
the computer write the first draft or
the Wikipedia article can you do that so
we did it now essentially you can go
here every single day and it will just
find people that it has detected as
having lots of information in public
site able sources where that information
seems to be missing from Wikipedia
so now like anyone anywhere anytime has
that cognitive that first really hard
cognitive bias problem
of what
pay attention to in the first place
solved at least for scientists Hey so is
I'm on this list does she have a page
yeah so I'm very proud to say that Emma
now has a Wikipedia page and this is a
good one so remember where I showed you
that Wikipedia page of the scientist
from Harvard kind of like modest no
image this is a better page it's
actually got more more sources it's it's
really well interlinked all those blue
letters are basically like wiki links
embedding this page within Wikipedia is
knowledge graph that interlinking is
really important so this is a good page
however I kid you not within two days of
this page getting created which by the
way was made by a Jess Wade all credit
due to her a collaborator and friend
based in the UK this this started to
appear in the talk page of Emma's
Wikipedia page so okay let's zoom in on
the logic behind that this is this is
how the door gets cracked open this is
this is the very beginning of the
process of deleting someone from
Wikipedia okay so the reason this person
gave for wanting to delete Emma's page
is they say that the computation may be
notable but that is not enough by itself
to make the person who did it notable so
it's a bit of a paradox right if if all
you're famous for is like winning the
Nobel Prize like really just the one
thing it just doesn't quite make the cut
and again these are not bad actors these
are just people like one of the one of
the many many volunteers just trying to
keep Wikipedia standards high but it's
hard like subjective task to decide what
the world should and should not know
about Paco please join us on stage so
we're going to do something with you
here now on this public stage at a
public event we are going to introduce
to you the first-ever notability award
we
called the cube UB and it is given to a
person who has abundant significant
information in public sizeable sources
about their life and work it's you know
it's a computationally generated prize
I think AI can start giving prizes to
humans that it learns things about and
the first ever QB thank you very much
goes to wait no it's not going to very
the very first the very first recipient
of the Lord sitting amongst us today
right here in the audience who could it
be
so let me open this one here this is
gonna win it I'm sure Deloitte will
invite you up to the food rip this Evan
it's a very exciting moment the
first-ever notability award goes to the
one the only Emma haruka you Wow please
join us in welcoming Emma come on up
[Applause]
[Music]